yeah and just to recap you heard police
right there say this starting
this started as a missing persons case
and now
it is a homicide investigation again
amari nicholson just
two years old reported missing on may
5th police saying it became clear the
circumstances
surrounding his disappearance were
suspicious an investigation took place
police are saying they knew that terrell
rhodes was their primary suspect
he is being booked in jail at the clark
county detention center
that charge is now murder police also
saying
another update here that he chose to
fight with police officers
as they were speaking with him and he
took an
officer's firearm they got it back but
again that's
another update in this investigation now
at this point sources tell me they have
not found
two-year-old amari's body but they also
tell me
again that terrell rhodes confessed now
let's go to video
eight news now reporter joe moeller
talked
with terrell rhodes and amari's mother
taylor nicholson on friday
terrell rhodes gave his version of
events saying that a woman
showed up to take amari i believe we
have that
interview or part of it queued up now
that's who i thought was gonna pick up
amari and as i'm
finna call my girlfriend and pack his
bag at the same time
she says that they already got
everything that they need for him and
i don't need to pack anything he he'd be
fine and she
regulated and she proceeded out the door
as i'm on the phone
so again there you heard from terrell
rhodes police are saying
he is now in jail accused of murder
for two-year-old amari nicholson now i
also
talked with amari's grandmother on his
mother's
side she thought all along she told me
that she believed
that the story was suspicious just as
police are now telling us
today of course this is an update that
none of us want to report again
now terrell rhodes is in jail police are
saying
he confessed to murdering two-year-old
amari nicholson
reporting live vanessa murphy eight news
now
vanessa thanks it is chilling to listen
to that piece of the interview there
joe moeller has been following this
story all week as well in fact he was
with the family earlier today the site
of the family that has been offering a
reward
he reached out to them after news of the
arrest this afternoon joe
yeah that's right amari's family on his
biological dad's side today was out here
trying to get this search continued
earlier today we did reach out to them
after news of
rhodes's arrest came out but as you can
imagine they're saddened by this and
they did not answer our phone calls the
emerald suites here is where
he was last seen amari last wednesday
this is just south of the convention
center on paradise the mother and her
boyfriend
were living here at the time now the
ants have been out for days helping look
for him
eight news now has been covering this
case since we learned the two-year-old
was missing
i spoke to amari's mom and her boyfriend
last friday rhodes told me
someone from the toddler's father's side
had picked him up that family has denied
that
all along there was missing parts of
this story he did not provide a
description of the person who picked up
amari he also said that person picked
him up
and left so quickly he basically
couldn't get to them omari's mother
stood by what rhodes was saying during
that interview friday
we reached out to taylor nicholson this
week as well but she has not been
returning contact and we did not see her
participating in the search that was
being put on now back out here live
you're taking another look at the
emerald suites we just
were over in this area talking to
someone who actually lived in this
complex they said that they were shocked
to hear about the outcome of this they
had police knocking on their door
when the search was happening throughout
this complex as well
we are waiting to get more information
as you can imagine the family of the
father's side they're completely shocked
by this as soon as we do learn more
we'll be sure to pass it along i'll send
it back to you
joe and vanessa thanks for that we are
just now getting this into our newsroom
this is the youtube video of the arrest
of terrell rhodes that happened just
earlier this afternoon as metro police
told us there was
a scuffle as they were trying to take
him into custody at one point he managed
to
get a hold of a metro police officer's
gun that was very quickly diffused we
understand
but this is youtube video that is just
now released of the
accused murderer of two-year-old amari
nicholson
just now being released from metro
police so again he is in custody
after a brief scuffle but now of course
the
the investigation shifts to where is
amari's remains so we're of course
keeping an eye on this for you and have
more throughout the newscast